[Musique]
voter pour le parti né ma liste d'une
part pour changer le sort des animaux
aux européennes d'autre part redonner
espoir aux jeunes qui sont aujourd'hui
blasé par l'ensemble des politiques et
on le voit clairement sur le terrain
lors des tractages aujourd'hui les
jeunes ne se reconnaissent plus dans les
programmes politiques traditionnels et
le parti d'humaniste propose un
programme vraiment différent je voudrais
citer alphonse de lamartine
on n'a pas de coeur un pour les animaux
et un pour les humains on a un coeur ou
n'en a pas le parti animalistes fait
partie d'un groupe de onze partis
animalistes en europe et nous partageons
un programme politique commun 248
mesures qui vont permettre d'améliorer
le sort des animaux en europe on parle
de l'ensemble des animaux aussi bien
terrestres et aquatiques dont on parle
aussi bien des animaux de compagnie on
est contrôlé fectivement l'abandon et on
veut justement que les abandons
d'animaux de compagnie soit puni on
parle également des animaux élevés des
animaux élevage d'élevage
je rappelle aujourd'hui que l'élevage
intensif est la première cause du
réchauffement climatique
donc en s'occupant justement des animaux
non humains on s'occupe également des
animaux humains et qui dit animalistes
dit humaniste nous sommes inclusif et
non exclusifs comme autre mesure
interdire la détention des animaux dans
les cirques m'interdire des traditions
telles que la tauromachie ou le gavage
des oies donc toutes ces mesures nous
souhaitons justement qu'elle soit menée
par l'europe car nous savons qu'en
france
rien ne bouge et rien ne viendra de la
[Musique]
89% des français considèrent que la
cause animale qui ne cause importante
c'est un sondage ifop de février 2019
lors des élections européennes il y à
plus de 60 % d'électeurs qui
s'abstiennent de voter si nous sommes
capables aujourd'hui de mobiliser ces
abstentionnistes qui se reconnaissent
dans la cause animale et qui considèrent
que la cause animale est une cause
prioritaire importante et bien nous les
appelons justement à voter on est
aujourd'hui pour les animaux tous
rassemblés pour défendre cette cause
donc aujourd'hui le parti animalistes il
défend une cause il défend pas une
couleur politique
on propose un vrai programme différent
en propose une approche différente et on
espère que les jeunes si on fait un
résultat important se décideront à se
réengager en politique
[Musique]